ever since I moved to New York people
are always asking me if I've ever had a
New York moment like they'll say oh my
god a burner has be around unlike a New
York moment one time I saw a black guy
with a mohawk walked by a white guy with
a mohawk and they both died five so I
made a wish I know how miracles work but
apparently that's not real enough New
York moment cuz everyone's all like like
a New York moment you know I stopped and
I thought about it and I was like well
one time I saw a fresh pile of dog poop
with the used condom oh I know I was
there that's when I came up with a game
called too much information or not
enough you're right there are no winners
in that game you just start an Instagram
account and you keep it moving so then I
started to think maybe I never have a
real New York moment and then one day
I'm walking down the street we're not
that different you and I and I see a
delivery truck rolling down the hill
with no driver in it and at first I
didn't pick up on it right away you know
cuz it wasn't about me
but then I saw UPS driver running after
the truck and I was like I went to
college I know what's going on here in
the UPS truck headed straight for the
Diana bison game and then as I've been a
movie UPS driver power jogs up to the
truck there's a lazy triple axel in the
driver's seat how's the brake like an
old-timey train conductor
the guy on the bike dyeing the bike
looks up the guy in the truck they share
this long moment and then I swear to you
they boat you shrug as if to go no I was
like seriously that's it
but then the stranger walking by out of
nowhere hands me this giant slice of
pizza all right get the hive I got the
hive
[Music]
you